欢迎各位说明今天这期百车全说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊特斯拉。
有人说特斯拉不是聊过了吗？
今天其实聊的是特斯拉的电池供应商，
或者说叫特斯拉的电池电星的供应商。
之前它一共有四家，分别是林德时代、比亚迪、松夏和LG。
那么如果大家最近看汽车新闻的话应该知道，
新旺达正式成为特斯拉全球第五家动力电视供应商。
今天咱们就聊一聊这个事情。
那么前两家或者说前面几家的合作模式，
其实跟现在新旺达的这个合作模式它不太一样。
而且大家其实对于可能林德时代比较了解，
对于比亚迪也比较了解，
但是对于松夏和LG的相关的情况不是特别的了解。
那么今天节目里面咱们也是可以简单的展开介绍一下。
那么对于大家将来买车会有一些帮助。
那么新旺达目前跟特斯拉的合作就是。
它只向特斯拉提供最最最基础的零酸铁里的电星，
大家注意是电星不是电池。
那这有什么区别呢？
就是它的这个电星啊会从浙江义物的工厂。
然后先运到上海特斯拉自己的工厂，
然后进行一个模组或者说叫做park的一个组装。
我们之前其实在去沈阳，
就是我去探访宝马的动力电视工厂的时候，
它是有动力电视一期工厂二期工厂嘛。
我就曾经说过就是宝马的这个电车，
它就是先从林德时代把电星运过来，
然后在沈阳自己的动力电视工厂进行一个park的一个组装，
然后再装在自己的车上，
比方说像宝马的i3啊RX3啊这样的车。
那么新旺达的这个电星装在特斯拉的车上，
你今后买特斯拉是不是会就是买到的就不是林德时代的，
就是新旺达的呢可能性不大，
为什么呢？
因为目前得到的信息就是它在新旺达电星的这一批车呢，
是出口到欧洲的啊出口到欧洲特斯拉，
所以呢在国内基本上是买不到的，
那除非就是特斯拉内部啊可能基于某些原因，
他告诉你说我的电星是浑装的啊，
有可能你能买到林德时代也可能能买到这个这个新旺达的啊，
而且你要注意他用的这个新旺达的只是他的林酸铁你的电星，
那么之前特斯拉和林德时代的合作模式呢，
就是特斯拉直接向林德时代采购他的模组，
就是直接把电池包打过来装上去，
所以这两种模式是有比较大的区别的啊，
我们后面会展开来具体去讲，
那么国内的电池的厂商呢，
那一线的就不用说绝对就是林德时代啊，
包括像比亚迪都属于是一线的，
而这个新旺达啊，
包括像国宣高科啊，
福能科技啊，
意味你能啊这些，
我们民间讲就算是二线，
因为他们官方肯定是不愿意承认嘛，
谁是一线谁是二线，
你怎么去评判，
你是按照出货量还是按照他的品质，
还是按照技术含量还是怎样，
对吧，还是公司市值，
不过你就是按照这几个维度去评判，
那林德时代仍然是第一，
比亚迪仍然是第一线的，
对不对，
那么关于新旺达这几年的事情，
可以说不算少了，
网上的新闻报道也挺多的，
那么最最最热门的一个事件，
就是极客子公司威瑞，
之前因为极客001的电信质量缺陷，
那么对新旺达发起了23.14亿的一个索赔，
而且是素质法庭，
两边是打官司了，
那么这个事情到最后其实也没有一个什么结果，
最后说是什么和解了，
然后相互怎么赔偿啊什么的那个的，
那么官方其实新旺达也没有去解释说，
他这个电信到底有没有问题，
所以呢双方就是把这个钱谈妥了，
该赔多少钱，分什么时间段去给，
他们自己去解决就行了，
那么包括新旺达他的电信，
也是曾经用在WOW的EX30上面，
那么当时也是因为有过热的风险，
在海外也发起过召回，
那么新旺达的电信到底质量怎么样，
其实说实话虽然官方没给解释，
但是大家对于这些新闻事件的了解，
或者说通过一些零零散散的一些信息接受，
其实印象不咋地，
对新旺达的就是你买车的时候可以看到说是新旺达的电信，
只要但凡不是唯一的选择，
很多人会说我不要新旺达，
我要那个其他的哪怕是国宣的，
或者是其他的那些什么福能科技的，
我就不要新旺达的，
会不会出现这样的情况肯定是有的，对吧，
但是我今天想讲的就是，
其实你不用担心，
因为特斯拉将来用新旺达的电信的这些车子大部分，
或者说是全部都是出口在欧洲的车型上，
那么会不会用在咱们国内的特斯拉车型上不是很清楚，
但是车肯定是在咱们国内上海遭的，
对吧，有没有可能有一批车，
比方说国内卖的特别好，
国外那边滞销，
但是这批车国内这边供不上了，
那怎么办呢，
那你不出口了吗，
那车子出口转内销，
这个可能性有没有，
我觉得按照特斯拉这种调性，
只要能卖的出去也是有这种可能性的，
但是目前的信息就是，
只用在出口欧洲的车型上，
那么特斯拉其实一直是一个非常难缠的假方，
为什么这么讲呢，
据我们了解，
他对于供应商的要求其实并不是特别低，
或者说其实一点都不低，
因为他经常会，
比方说很小的一些故障率，
就开始召回一大批的车型，
这对于消费者来讲肯定是好事嘛，
对吧,
但是对于供应商来讲，
其实是怎么说呢，
就要求比较苛刻，
而且一点面子就不给，
你比如说之前他召回过两万多台Model 1，
为什么召回这两万多台，
因为他当时就直接点名，
就是产自拓谱的转向节，
有0.2%到1%的缺陷概率，
有人讲这也不是很高，
但你要知道他的产量是非常大的，
0.2%到100%车里面，
可能就有一台车出现缺陷，
那么你想一年卖个几十万辆，
那这是什么概率，
他一个月就是几万台的销量啊，
是不是，
所以这件事情就导致拓谱集团的股价滑滑的往下掉，
所以呢，
他能在电星电池关键的部件上满足特萨的要求，
我觉得希望达这家公司多多少少还是有点东西的，
但是话又说回来，
你说哪家公司没有一点黑历史呢，
你说是不是，
那么特斯拉现在已经有四家电视供应商了，
我们前面说的林德时代比亚迪，
然后包括松夏和LG，
那么体量一个比一个大，
按道理说他的供应量其实根本不用担心，
那为什么还要再加一个希望达呢，
那么有人说是为了供应链多元化，
还有人说是为了去供应商化，
那其实这两点呢都是核心原因，
确实是的，
那么供应链的多元化说白了就是，
他增加电星电池的供应的来源，
然后分散对单一供应商的一个依赖的风险，
这个我相信只要但凡做过生意的，
哪怕没做生意你多少懂一点这个生意上的这个规律你就知道，
我不能完全依赖一家供应商，
那万一他要是跟我撂挑子，
他要是跟我谈这个价格要往上涨一涨，
那我是没有其他的办法的，
如果我用他的这一套体系已经用习惯了，
所以他要去分散这个风险，
那么十几年前特斯拉是只依赖松夏的独家供应，
大家应该记得是吧，
那么后来他就逐步引入了林德时代，
然后又引入了比亚迪，
后来又有LG，
所以现在是四家嘛，
今天这个时间点他又扶持这个希望达去上位，
形成了五家供应商并存的格局，
那么供应商一多选择的余地就多了，
那么价格自然就好谈，
你给我的价格高我就用其他家的，
那么这就是第一点就是供应商的多元化对吧，
分散分险很好理解，
那么第二个叫做去供应商化是什么意思呢，
我们简单来讲特斯拉其实也想做自己的电池，
就是他不想被这些电池供应商牵着别自走，
因为我们知道特斯拉其实什么都想自己做嘛，
不管是软件也好硬件也好都想自己做，
但是电池这一块呢就是特斯拉一直感觉没整明白，
按道理讲按到特斯拉的这种就是不管是从经济的体量来讲，
还是说他的这个技术研发的实力来讲的话，
做电池应该不难我觉得，
但是这里面可能涉及到这个产业链的一整套体系，
上下游的一整套体系，
所以特斯拉一直是被电池供应商牵着别自走，
就早期其实一直是这样子的，
这个事情让我想到什么呢，
就是想到iPhone，
iPhone之前一直想要去自己做基带，
因为这个iPhone它一直信号不是很好，
这个我太了解了，
你看我从以前iPhoneX到iPhone13，
用起来就是这个电话叫什么呢，
就是我让我想到以前的小铃通了，
小铃通有个外号叫做微微靠，
什么意思呢，拿起电话，
微微靠，
哈哈哈就是接电话就是信号总是不行，
对方那边也听不到我讲话，
然后我这边听到他讲话也是端端虚虚，
就是微微靠，
叫微微靠，
但是现在我换了iPhone17之后，
我觉得信号好很多了，
那么这里面就涉及到一个基带的问题，
我曾经看到一篇文章具体的，
因为太专业我也说不上来，
大概的意思就是，
就是iPhone虽然它资金实力很强，
研发实力很强，
但是在基带这一块，
它确实是干不过华为，
而且就是全球真正做基带做的最好的，
好像就那么两家，
一个华为，
还有一个是高通吧还是谁，
我记得，就这两家，
然后呢就是苹果一直想自己做，
一直做不出来，
这里面也是涉及到上下游，
一整套的体系的问题，
匹配的问题，
这里面的有些可能是写一个方面的东西，
他要把它完整的上下游这条链全部打通，
而且想都掌握在自己手里面是非常难的，
所以说特斯拉他就一直想，
不被电池供应商牵着鼻子走，
一直想要自己去掌握电池的核心技术，
之前不是搞那个4680电池吗？
4680相当于就是他自己种个菜，
然后自己去做饭，
自己端上饭，
然后端上菜自己吃，
但这个事情太难了，
技术和量产一直没有完全搞定，
所以就现在一直没听说特斯拉就把其他的供应商全部踢掉，
然后全部用自己的4680是吧，
很多特粉其实一直很期待这个电池吗？
不过特斯拉他其实一直没放弃，
本质上来讲他就是想全产业链都掌握在自己手里面，
所以他就换了一个思路，
不再直接去买别人做好的整核电池，
就是整个的这个电池包，
而是只买最基础的电芯，
剩下来怎么组装，
怎么散热，
怎么控制成本都是自己说了算，
自己来决定，
所以说白了就是以前供应商卖给特斯拉的是成品，
那么现在卖给他的是原材料，
那么这样的话特斯拉对于成本性能，
包括供应链的话语权就会更大一些，
但是以上并没有解释清楚说，
为什么现在如日中天的特斯拉会选择一个小小的二线电池厂，
也就是新旺达，
那么之前我们讲特斯拉合作的这些供应商，
林德时代比亚迪松下LG，
那一顶一的都是电池巨头，
那新旺达跟这些品牌比根本就比不了，
是不是，其实我想讲道理也很简单，
第一个一定是它便宜嘛，
对不对，进货价便宜，
特斯拉是一个特别看重成本的一个企业，
那么第二个是什么，就是听话，
那么这里面听话我们觉得有几个方面可以理解，
第一个就是特斯拉可以跟他谈比较灵活的一种合作方式，
那么第二个就是我猜新旺达有可能也会给他一些技术支撑，
因为林德时代比亚迪这种你想跟他谈技术方面的一些转让，
或者说你能不能教我怎么去造电池，
或者说你能不能把你一些上下游的供应链体系，
也把它移植到我特斯拉特斯拉这里面来，
我估计比较难，
但是新旺达一旦是要是能把它给为的比较薄，
一旦是让他能觉得说我吃特斯拉这一单，
或者我拿着特斯拉这个案例去吃别人的订单，
因为你想想看我是特斯拉的电池供应商，
那我可以去赚别人的钱，
那有没有可能他最后会成为特斯拉的一个技术的供应商，
不仅仅是电芯的供应商，
这是我的猜测，
所以我觉得重点是这两点，
那么在此之前我们想先提一下目前特斯拉一个大背景，
那么去年也就是2025年，
特斯拉帽多外是全球范围内卖的最好的单一车型，
我也曾经专门做过一些节目，
后来因为一些我也不知道什么原因这个节目就没了，
所以大家要听在小宇宙或者其他平台都能听得到，
喜马拉雅是被下架了，
其他平台都在，
那么从财报的数据上来看的话，
去年其实是特斯拉过的最惨的一年，
有人说不对啊，
你刚刚不是说Model Y是全球销量最好的车型吗？
对，它是所有车型，
不仅仅是电车啊，
是包括邮车，
它是销量最好的车，
但是业绩，
业绩对于特斯拉来讲，
这个公司相当于是成立以来首次下滑，
它2025年的营收和2024年相比，
首次下滑了3%，
规模净利润更是大幅的下滑，
只有37.94亿美元，
有人讲说中国的钱37亿，
接近38亿这也不算少，
但是你要知道它跟2024年比，
下滑了46%，
那么46%什么概念，
几乎等同于腰斩了，
那么同时全球新车交付量，
它是持续第二年开始下滑了，
那么下滑到了163.6万辆，
这么一家能够一年销量在百万，
快接近度过160麻，
再往后上面冲一冲，
能到200万辆，
也是一家大公司了，
而且它是一个卖纯电车的公司啊，
你想一想，
但是对于它来讲的话，
就是持续两年下滑，
所以它的汽车业务的营收，
同比下降了10%，
那么在剃除这个叫做碳积分之后，
它的汽车的毛利率为15.4%，
15.4%其实已经很高了，
已经很高了，
但是对于它来讲，
跟它的之前的利润率比，
那确实也是差了很多，
不是跟去年，
我们如果是跟它的2021年的最高点去比的话，
那它其实将近于是砍了一半，
因为2021年的时候相当于它的毛利率。
能到30%左右，
现在就15.4%，
那么同时在咱们中国这个市场呢，
特斯拉甚至出现了，
就是即使降价也挽回不了销量的局面，
我指的销量并不出它卖的很惨很惨，
而是没有到以前的那个高峰期，
或者没有到以前的那种规模，
那么它的市场份额也是从6%降到了4.9%，
这个应该讲就有所下降，
并不是说降得很很，
排名是由第三排到的第五，
所以说它在Optimus，
包括Robotaxi,。
就相当于是人形机器人和那个不人驾驶苏车，
这两个地方它需要持续烧钱嘛，
这是它花的大笔嘛，
那么汽车业务其实是持续要给特斯拉供应它的现金流的，
相当于是它的现金奶流嘛，
对吧，就是它的主要收入来源，
所以你不要光看特斯拉卖的还是非常不错，
但是它其实我觉得这公司内部应该是非常着急的，
非常焦急的，
你比如说前段时间它的这个车型战略上面。
就做了一个非常大的调整，
它把不赚钱的Model X和Model X给直接砍掉了，
有人讲砍就砍没，这两台车本身卖的也不多，
虽然说卖的不多，
但你要知道这两台车对于特斯拉来讲的话，
其实是具有符号化的定义的，
Model X的这种展翼门的这种创新，
Model X在中国当时第一批的特斯拉车主，
你包括当时你还记得像理想啊，
还有像那个什么新浪创始人还是谁，
就是一批全是国内的这种高静置人群，
甚至可以说是商界的名人，
而且都是一些跟互联网相关的一些名人，
或者投资公司的那种大佬，
那你想想看他们当时是第一批特斯拉Model X的车主，
这就是无形的背书嘛，
所以这两台车当时是有符号化的一个意义的，
但是对于现在这个时代来讲的话，
因为不赚钱对吧，
因为销量极低也不具备什么样的存在的价值了，
直接给砍掉，
它讲的就是成本化，
就是成本一定要最低，
让公司往最挣钱的方向去走，
所以说你要想多挣钱，
那么你想一台车上它的这个成本占比最高的是什么，
那其实就是电池嘛，
对不对，电池的成本相当于是占了它整个的这台电池的成本的30%，
30应该可能都不止，
30多,
那么所以特斯拉肯定是第一个要拿这个电池供应商来进行开刀的嘛，
那么林德时代比亚迪松下LG的电池好不好，
那肯定是好的嘛，
这种大规模的这个生产，
包括这种大品牌大公司的品控肯定是没有问题的，
但是呢有技术沉淀，
有这个相关的经验，
也足够的靠谱，
也能满足特斯拉非常高的要求，
这都是没有问题的，
但是唯一的问题是什么，
那就是贵，
因为大公司大品牌，
而且出货量也不低，
它价格肯定是不便宜的，
对不对，
你要如果想要便宜的，
那我刚刚前面讲了，
那国内那么多的二线的电池供应商，
你可以去找它，
你为什么要找这些的又是中国的，
又是日本的，
又是韩国的电池供应商呢，
我们以林德时代为例啊，
那么林德时代是供应着特斯拉在中国市场和欧洲市场，
绝大部分的零算贴地电池，
那么甚至占到了特斯拉全球电池采购的四成到五成，
这个比例非常高了，
你想想看前面是四家电池供应商，
就光林德时代一家就占到了四到五成，
它是特斯拉目前最大的电池供应商，
虽然我不知道，
就是林德时代供给特斯拉的电池有多贵，
但是呢，
我们从它公布的业绩来看，
就是林德时代的电池绝对是不便宜的，
2025年,
林德时代全球动力电池的使用量，
它的市占率提升到了39.2%，
那么同比增加了1.2个百分点，
连续9年位居全球第一，
是地球上最大的电池供应商，
那么国内的动力电池的装机量市占率达到了43.42%，
全年实际的实现营收相当于是4237.02亿元，
那么同比增长17.04%，
你想想看，
这种规模的公司还能两位数的增长，
这非常夸张的，
它实现的规模经历润722.01亿元，
很夸张，
所以你说它的电池供应的价格会便宜吗，
肯定不便宜啊，
722亿的规模经历润什么概念，
我记得当年我玩王者荣耀的时候，
我记得王者荣耀当时一年的利润差不多也是6700还是7800个亿啊，
然后之前能看到一年百亿利润的，
好像就是中国移动中国电信的吧，
其他的公司我实在想不到还有哪些能这么挣钱的，
那么林德时代相当于就是同比增长了42.28%，
利润这一块也是增长42%，
创下了历史新高，
那么林德时代如果是单看动力电池部分，
它的毛利率达到了23.84%，
比同行业普遍高出5%到15%，
我们刚刚讲特斯拉的它的毛利也就是14%还是13%，
特斯拉的毛15.4%，
特斯拉毛利也就15.4%，
国内的很多的新能源车企卷到现在都不挣钱了，
百分比就是这个利润的百分比就是4或者是5，
现在可能都掉到3了，
你再看看这些电池的供应上，
这么挣钱我的天，毛利率23.84%，
比同行业还要高出5%到15%，
所以你如果按照这个推测的话，
那么林德时代实际上它的价格有可能就是比同行业要高出个10%左右，
大啥不啥吧，
那么无论是销量，营收还是利润，
其实林德时代都堪称是非常无敌的就是史上或者地球上最强的电池巨头，
就哪怕就是强如特斯拉这样的公司，
我觉得在他的面前可能也要稍微低一低头，
所以特斯拉的这个姿态肯定也会放他稍微低一点，
那么林德时代林王嘛，
他的价格肯定就不会说任你特斯拉随便砍随便那个啥，
你爱买就买不买我也不差你这一家，
我估计就是这种心态啊，
所以换句话讲，
特斯拉其实也逃脱不了给林王打工的命运，
那么其他的供应商呢？
那其他的供应商比如说松下LG，
那么主打的是三元里电池，
我们也知道特斯拉其实在全球市场卖三元里电池高配设型嘛，
他其实也不是特别多啊，
他的占比不是特别的高，
那么因为三元里电池天然他成本就比较高，
尤其像松下，
松下他自身的毛利率仅仅就在5%左右，
你跟林王怎么比啊，
林王20%多啊，
他5%左右，
所以说他因为利润率本身就不高，
所以你再让特斯拉跟他砍价，
确实也比较难砍，
所以呢特斯拉就把目光转向了二线厂商，
寻找这种平替，
那么这个时候就轮到新旺达上场了，
其实新旺达在此之前跟特斯拉并不是不熟悉，
两家是有合作过的，
是怎么合作的呢，
2022年的时候，
当时新旺达就开始给特斯拉供应12伏的零酸铁里启动电池，
也就是我们讲的就小电池，
所以二线厂商当中，
首选新旺达我觉得也是顺利成章的事情，
对吧,
特斯拉毕竟在中国带那么多年了嘛，
对不对，
那么这个用人不用生，
有熟人那肯定是先用嘛，
对不对，
我不讲嘛，
马斯克来中国上那个酒桌子，
那也要首先把杯子端起来敬酒啊，
敬酒的时候也得弯个腰啊，
那个杯子也得往下放啊，
对不对，
我先喝，
我一干为敬，
我老马一干为敬，
要不然你哪能在中国吃那么多红利呢，
你说是不是，
这个具体大家也没见过，
只是猜想一下啊，
他应该上了酒桌子，
要熟悉咱们中国的酒文化，
那么首先啊，
我还是回到这个事情上来讲，
新旺达的电池，
肯定是比零德时代便宜，
对不对，
这个大家肯定都是认可的，
那么因为他们家的财报也能看得出来，
他们走的路线和零德也是不一样的，
零德时代是可以通过技术领先实现高一价的，
而新旺达，
他一直走的都是博力多销的性价比路线，
因为了解新旺达的人也知道，
新旺达其实给苹果也供过这个电池嘛，
因为新旺达是做消费电池起家的，
那么目前他还不完全靠动力电池赚钱，
不完全靠，
2025年上半年他动力电池相关的营收业务，
同比增长了22.63%也还算可以了，
两位数增长，
但是毛利率却比之前下降了1.89%，
降到了9.77%，
所以我不说嘛，
零亡20%多的这种毛利率，
那绝对是非常夸张的，
非常夸张的，
那基本上他这个新旺达的毛利率，
只有零德时代一万不到的水平，
你甚至可以说他就是赔本专要和嘛，
对吧,
那么其次新旺达他肯定是比零德时代更听话，
这也是我们前面讲的二线的厂商，
那其实双方合作有的时候他不一定是对等的，
签的协议也不一定是完全公平的协议，
只不过他们内部不会给你知道，
所以他作为国内排名比较靠谴，
只能说比较靠谴，
一般都是在大概全国的第五到第七名的这样一个电池的厂商，
新旺达他不仅出货量，
他在二线厂商当中其实还算可以，
那么近几年跟，
包括像小米、理想，
包括上汽东风这些车企合作关系也是挺好的，
那么最重要的是什么，
就是他们家口碑也没有网上传的那么差，
因为车企厂商也不傻，
难道说比网友傻吗？
网友天天说看到新旺达我就不买，
看到新旺达我就不要，
新旺达的电池肯定有问题，
其实这些都是给媒体报道带节奏带出来的，
说白了这家公司的品供不至于有那么差，
你看他的市场占有量跟那么多的汽车品牌，
包括那些消费电子的品牌去合作，
就不至于那么差，
人家也是一个老牌的公司，
只不过出扩量或者说是产品的定位，
跟我们所想象中的像铃王这种差距还是有的，
所以如果比方有一些混装电池，
你除了新旺达也能选其他的，
像铃德时代这样的品牌，
那你去优选这是没有任何问题的，
但如果说都是二线的一些品牌，
那其实剩下来就要看什么了，
就要看车企对于电池供应商的品供的要求，
它会制定一定的标准，
双方会一起来去制定相关的标准，
这个我觉得就很重要了，
所以这家电池的供应商跟车企之间的配合度高不高，
也非常的重要，
那么之前汽车行业有一个传闻，
说希望达当时拿下小米昆仑的项目之后，
就直接派了一个大概四五十人的团队，
就入驻到上海京桥小米办公室的旁边，
这个情绪价值直接拉满了嘛，
其实这种故事我们之前也讲过，
大家还记得当时宝马第一个跟林德时代合作，
去造汽车的动力电池，
林德时代造汽车动力电池，
其实也是宝马带入门的嘛，
然后中间就开始传闻了嘛，
说哎呀宝马派了恩多的工程师，
直接睡在工厂吃在工厂，
给他说列了一个什么800多页的电池的相关的标准，
从此之后林德时代就学会了怎么样去做汽车的动力电池，
之后也是林德时代比较感恩嘛，
就是宝马去做当时的电车叫芝诺还记得吗，
芝诺其实就是当时林德时代第一批装车的量产的动力电池，
这个故事我们曾经也讲过的，
那么现在兴旺达他就相当于在当下这个时代，
也跟当年的林德时代一样，
就像个小迷地找各种车企去合作，
然后配合度特别的高，
在旁边住搭办公室，
然后情绪价值拉满，
那么包括跟理想的合作，
据说这个兴旺达当时直接是将电芯电池，
这些研发核心的环节交给理想来把控，
然后他自己是专注于制造代工，
那么说实话你说完全交给理想有可能吗，
我觉得也不太可能，
那肯定也是派相关的专家，
然后也要去跟他进行或者说叫指导，
或者说是叫做叫什么叫全程带运营，
我也不能叫带运营叫全程陪跑，
我觉得陪跑这个词应该是可以的，
其实相当于就是把自己的一些技术就直接交给厂家了嘛，
这个我觉得也是马斯克特别想要的一点，
那我相信马斯克在去用这个希望达作为他第五家供应商的时候，
肯定也是了解过他之前跟小米，
之前跟理想的合作形式是什么样子的，
他如果发现这里面不仅仅是价格便宜，
而且他很听话，
并且能够可能在某些技术层面上来讲，
能交自己一点东西，
那是没有任何问题的，
而且说白了，
他不就等于是一个地主娶了五个老婆嘛，
对不对，
哪个老婆表现好一点就对吧，
这个他自己心里就有数，
哪天他要把哪个老婆给修掉，
这个说不准啊，
对吧,
就虽然说讲这个可能在某些节目平台上是比较犯记的，
因为现在大家知道，
我们的女同胞都特别不愿意听这些东西，
但是他其实事实上就是这样，
马斯克不就想当于是娶了五个老婆嘛，
那随时随地就可以换嘛，
因为这些供应商跟他又不是强保定的，
是不是，
那换换句话讲，
这些供应商也不是他一个老公啊，
他背后也是有很多的嘛，
就像最近那个奥普的广告是吧，
说我,
我的爸爸有两个老婆，
一个是什么，
另外一个是什么，
那广告说实话我也没看懂，
他到底什么意思，
我到现在我也没看懂，
就莫名其妙的一个广告，
而且你想想看这种广告放到网上，
那么铁定要被人喷嘛，
是不是，
好，我们再回到节目上来讲啊，
所以他这种姿态，
其实相比铃王肯定是低的不止一星半点嘛，
我说的是新网打啊，
新网打只要是车企想合作，
那条件也不能说认你开吧，
就是条件肯定能放得很低的，
然后呢，
形式是由车企来选，
方向是由车企来定，
所以这次跟特斯拉的合作肯定是一样的，
具体方宽到什么样的一个标准，
具体的大家感兴趣再往上去搜一搜，
因为它里面有很多的一些相关的报道啊，
那么他给特斯拉目前肯定知道的，
就快不是完整的电池包，
是最最最基础的铃钻铁里的电星，
那么剩下电池结构三热系统，
管理系统整包的这个分装啊这些工序，
都是特斯拉在自己的动力电池工厂里面做，
所以他呢一个就是不赚这个钱，
二一个他既是不赚钱，
难道说特斯拉大手一挥，
说你来过来帮我解决一下这个问题，
他能不去解决吗，
对吧，你该帮忙还是得帮忙啊，
哈哈哈哈，
我们俗称叫白嫖是吧，
但是呢我觉得是双赢啊，
我觉得双赢，
一方面他不仅仅是摆脱了对前面这四家供应商的一个依赖，
那么同时呢他又找到了一个既便宜又听话的新供应商，
这里面其实在国内来讲的话，
因为我们刚刚讲LG，
包括松夏这两个一个是日本一个是韩国的供应商，
他其实对于国内的零德时代的依赖度就没有那么高了，
因为零德时代的他供的也是零酸铁礼嘛对吧，
那我现在不用你零德时代的我用他的也可以，
只不过目前用他的是往欧洲去去发货啊，
但零德现在是国内欧洲都发嘛，
那么同时他又找到一个配合度很高很听话的这么一个供应商，
那么至于技术方面会不会也出让一些给特斯拉，
这个就不好说了嘛，
所以特斯拉他其实从新旺达这里可以得到我们刚刚讲的这些好处，
那么反过来新旺达是不是也能从特斯拉这边带来一些好处呢，
那肯定是有的，
那首先他的出货量肯定一下就上来了嘛，
毫无疑问的特斯拉这种体量级，
那么第二一个他肯定是会拿特斯拉这种合作案例去开拓其他的客户，
那么这就跟很多的供应商他就是赔钱也要去跟苹果公司合作，
是一个道理嘛对不对，
你能进入到苹果公司的供应商的这个体系里面，
你开玩笑啊，
你拿出去找别人去任何一家消费电子的这个厂商去合作，
哪个不认你啊，
他还会跟别人讲的，
你看我们用的这个产品是同样供给苹果公司的这个配件供应商，
他自己也会觉得很有面子啊，
这人和人之间都是相互的嘛对吧，
人台人高嘛，
是不是社交的本质就是资源互换嘛，
好我们再讲一讲其他的一些电视供应商，
其实今天这些节目既然聊到这了，
我觉得前面关于新旺达的故事也讲的差不多了，
我们可以再了解了解，
你比如说像这个，
我们刚讲的松下，
包括像LG，
甚至包括三星，
2025年全球上排的行动原车包含油混，
插混，增尘，纯电，
就但凡是用电池的，
他的动力电池的装车量合计达到了1187GW10，
你不用知道这里面具体什么GW10啊1187是什么概念，
你只要知道很多很多就可以了，
那么同比增长了31.7%，
从厂商装车量的排名来看，
依然是中、韩、日三足鼎力，
其他国家就根本插手不了，玩不了这个东西，
前10当中有6家都是中国的厂商，
你说中国到底新能源强到什么程度了，
零德时代，
比亚迪，
中创新航，
国宣高科，
义伟理伦，
还有分双能源，
这6家,
应该大家听的名字都比较熟悉是吧，
那么另外4家是谁呢，
另外4家就是日韩的这个电视供应商，
一个就是日本的松下，
另外的3个呢都是韩国的，
韩国的LG新能源，
SK-ON和三星SDI，
那么在市占率方面更加的恐怖啊，
前10当中有6家是中国厂商，
2025年合计突破，
市占率70.4%，
这什么概念啊，
这6家几乎相当于就是全球垄断了嘛，
动力电池这一块，
就是你想七成以上的市场，
都是咱们中国的电视供应商供应的，
那么2022年的时候，
这个市占率还只有60.4%，
而且这里面零德时代一家，
就是39.2的市占率非常夸张，
而且是产连全球动力电池市场的冠军，
39.2,
2025年的这个市占率，
还是在2024年的基础上提升的，
2024年是38%,。
所以你想想看它这种规模体量，
在这种非常卷的环境里面，
它还能再增长1.2个百分点，
所以你想想看这个铃王，
它到底有多强，
所以它的股票难怪，
对吧，卖的那么贵，
它的股票一般人都不敢入啊，
至少我就不敢入啊，
我觉得这家公司的整体的市值，
包括它的这个股票的单价，
特别的夸张，
就上下波动一下，
像我们这种小心脏，
每天可能就没有心思搞创作了，
所以我就宁愿不去碰它，
我就不敢去碰它，
而且你想想看它排名第一，
它的装车量，
几乎是排名第二的比亚迪的2.4倍啊，
所以它不是说，
是第一、第二、第三，
就是可能保持一点点的小差距，
不是一点点啊，
是很多很多啊，
2.4倍啊,
那么至于说，
装车量的增速，
那么咱们这些中国电视场上，
其实普遍是保持在30%到80%的高速增长，
那么其中最强眼的就是国宣高科，
国宣高科最近这两年增长速度非常狂涨，
最近这一年是增长速度达到了82.5%，
那意味理论，
包括像分超能源，
这些增速基本都超过60%，
你要知道2025年，
全球动力电池装车量的增长平均啊，
也就是31.7%，
所以换句话讲，
中国这些电池的供应商，
哪基本上都跑赢大盘了，
非常卷，
所以你不能光说车旗卷，
在电池供应商更卷，
那么相较于中国厂商的爆发式增长，
其实日韩厂商就没有那么卷了，
他们的业绩看起来就没有那么耀眼了，
你比如说韩国的电池三巨头，
对吧,
刚刚我们前面讲的LGSK跟三星，
这三家它的合计的施战率也是下降了，
2025年相比于2024年下降3.4%，
那么降到了15.3%，
其中的LGSK它依然是。
仅次于林德时代和比亚迪的全球第三，
装车量同比增长11.3%，
但是市场份额从10.9%下滑到9.2%，
SK的比例就比较小了，
SK的装车量同比虽然有增长，
增长了12.3%，
但是市场份额也是从4.4%降到了3.7%，
这个就几乎可以忽略不计了，
那么三星的装车量同比下降了6.9%，
它的这个施战率其实更小，
它的市场份额是从3.4%下滑到2.4%，
那么三星同样也是，
我们讲就是排名前十的这几家电视供应商当中。
唯一出现负增长的一个企业，
所以你看最近三星不是把这个家电，
那个什么电视机家家电这些全部从中国撤出去了吗，
撤完之后据说也是大规模的要采撤这一部分的这个员工，
就最近三星的一些负面新闻也挺多的，
那么我们再讲日本，
日本的松下它的施战率3.7%，
其实也不高，
那么相比于2024年就微微的降了0.1%，
相当于就是稳中有一点点小降，
那么说白了，
就不是说日韩的这些电视供应商，
它不努力，
他们的装车量大多都是增长，
但是中国的厂商实在是太给力，
中国的电视供应商真的是太绝了，
所以导致他们的施战率反而是下降，
而且这里面还有一个非常核心的原因是什么，
中国的电池厂商，
它吃的是中国的新能源车高速增长的红利，
因为咱们国内的新能源市场火爆，
那么咱们国内的新能源市场火爆，
你觉得日韩的电池厂商能吃到这个红利吗？
你见过哪一辆国展新能源的车，
装的是松下的电池，
LG的电池，
SK的三星的电池，
怎么可能呢？
想都不用想，
首先是绝对不可能从海外进口电池，
装到自己的国展新能源车上的，
其次也不可能给这些电池厂在国内大规模的建厂，
我不知道这些品牌在国内有没有厂，
就算有我觉得规模也非常的小，
而且一定是谈好了一些条件，
比方说生产的车辆，
装上电池，
然后就出口海外，
至少在国内的新能源车里面是绝对见不到的，
你为什么要舍尽球员呢？
咱们国内的电池本身做的就很好，
实战率又那么高，
凭空位也不错，
关键价格也合理，
你为什么还要去用LG、三星这些电池呢？
为什么要用日本的松下电池呢？
现在本身中日两国的关系这么紧张，
你要但凡敢用的话，
你试试看，
这绝对是会出大问题的，
这不是出的是质量问题，
是意识层面的问题的问题，
所以说中国的新能源市场在全球也是占比非常的高，
中国这么大的一块市场，
这么好的一块红利，
但是日韩的这些电池车喜是根本吃不到的，
它一口都吃不到，
那怎么办呢？
所以说，
他们基本上都是以动力电池出海，
就是到欧美市场去做他们的这些市场的供应，
但是你要知道，
咱们国内的电池供应上也在出海，
零德时代2025年动力电池海外的出货量占比要超30%，
欧洲市占率接近40%，
比亚迪它2025年的前三季度动力电池的外贡比例突破了20%，
然后意味你能2025年海外收入是占比25%，
2025年抛开中国市场，
国际市场上的电池的将一个装车量前10里面，
同样也是有6家中国市场，
2024年当时前10只有4家，
它的整体市场分额现在已经是达到了47.2%，
而且零德时代依然是稳居第一，
就是在海外的市占率，
所以说日韩的电池供应商，
它很难吃到中国新能源市场的红利，
那么在隔壁的像东南亚市场又很注重新价比，
注重新价比它也玩不过中国的电池供应商，
所以他们只能是依靠欧美市场，
而且是主作高端，
但是这里面就有个问题，
欧美市场这个电车它的销量是在降温，
或者说是在下滑的，
那么降温是指欧洲这边，
欧洲这边2025年的电动汽车销量同比增长，
29.7%,
听到还是不错的，
达到了258.5万辆，
因为它基数比较低，
所以它的增幅就比较大，
那么这个数据听得还行，
就是你要知道这个增速其实相比于前线链是明显放缓的，
所以它不是一个更好的趋势，
而且欧盟一直是传闻要取消2035年的燃油车竞售令，
就严丑的现在2026年的，
也就那么89年的时间，
所以这就导致很多的车企电动化转型就全面推迟了嘛，
所以这么一来的话电池就更加难卖了嘛，
那么美国这边2025年的电动汽车销量同比下降了2%，
是这把你下降了，
是近10年来首次年度下滑，
新能源应该讲在我们的眼中，
应该都是真真日上啊，
都是在上涨啊，
你看刚刚我们讲到电池供应商，
那都是两位数都增长，
但是美国这边是下降了2%，
我们讲电动汽车整车销设，
近10年第一次下降，
第四季度当时降幅是最大的，
是同比大降36%，
还比暴跌46%，
而且跟特朗普也有一定的关系，
特朗普政府当时是在积极的减缓电动化转型，
包括废除7500美元的电动车税收底面，
这个一讲达就明白了嘛，
对吧，我废除这个你就拿不到补贴了嘛，
然后还挑战加州2035年零排放man date这样的一个规则，
包括也是推动有利于化石燃料的法规，
所以一切你都能看到，
它对于新能源这一块它不是特别的欢迎，
它要可能是保救业，
保税收，保制造业，
那么结果可想而知，
其实以LG为例，
它在欧洲的或者叫欧美的市场的专车量，
它的增速从2024年的25%，
就一路下滑到2025年的10%，
那么三星在欧美市场的专车量也是出现了负增长，
同比下降了15%，
甚至日韩的电子厂商，
他们对未来的预期也是很悲观的，
有一家自军公司当时就预测显示说，
2026年欧美电动汽车的销量会更加的惨难，
他们预计美国市场2026年全年的销量会大跌29%，
欧洲市场全年增速也会大幅泛缓制14%，
我们刚刚讲说欧洲这边还能增长个29.7%，
那么到了明年可能就只能增长到14%，
所以速度会越来越满越来越满，
这不是一个好的招头，
那么同时中国厂商也是在抢占欧美市场，
例如说林德时代，
德国的工厂已经是满产了，
就产不过来了都已经，
然后匈牙利的工厂17已经建成了，
这才是17，那后面可能还要建27，
对吧，然后国宣高科，
德国的基地也是在稳定的供货，
还有像中创新行在葡萄牙也是有工厂，
还有意味理能，
包括我们今天聊的新旺达在匈牙利也都有工厂，
也是在推进本土化生产，
所以大家看一看，
你按照全球的版图来讲的话，
原先已经把日韩的电视供应商挤到欧美市场上去了，
那么现在在欧洲又开始去建那么多本土化的工厂，
这么搞下去的话，日韩的厂商连欧洲市场基本上都要弄丢了，
那最后就升个美国市场了，
但是美国市场我们刚刚讲了，
特朗普里边的规定其实都是弱化新能源，
或者说是放缓新能源，
销量都在往下滑，
那他们到底干还是不干呢？
你想想看他们自己造的那些电视场，
每天机器一开那都要花钱的，
是吧，那么多工人要养着的，
那当然了，
这里面其实也有很多是日韩的电视供应商的自己的问题，
例如说他们当时是全面压住三元铁电池，
他们想走高端市场，
但是近年来大家都知道全球的零酸铁铁电池在动力电池的装车量当中，
渗透率是持续上升的，
2024年首次突破50%，
以前基本上都是三元铁电池的天下，
但是现在零酸铁的装车量是越来越高了，
2026年当时预计到年底应该能达到60%，
所以说市面上有可能零酸铁铁的占比会比三元铁电池更多，
那么日韩的厂商在零酸铁铁电池领域其实做的并不怎么样，
所以导致他们中低端的行动员市场基本上就没有任何的竞争力，
所以就把这一块市场就拱手让给了中国的这些电池厂商，
对吧,
最近这两年大家才想起来说哦，
零酸铁铁电池原来也可以能量密度那么高，
零酸铁电池原来也可以充电那么快，
哦，成本还更低，
但是他们想做的时候已经来不及了，
已经是国内的这些电池厂商的相关的技术，
研发上下游全部都打通了嘛，
我们就拿三星举个例子，
就好像我们就没有听说过国内哪些车是用的三星的电池对吧，
三星其实在我刚刚说在欧洲市场上其实它包括美国就是欧美两边供应的还是比较多的，
虽然它施然率不高，
我们讲几个典型的，
比方说像宝马的i4， i5， i7， iRX这些纯电车型的高配版本，
很多用的就是三星的电池，
还有美国那边的新视力车企Reviant我之前也介绍过的，
它们的车早期也是用的三星的电星，
然后包括像奥迪的Q6一创部分车型也是用的三星的电池，
还有像斯特兰蒂斯，
斯特兰蒂斯起下的像比方说Gyp的新能源，
Reviant的新能源都是会用三星的电池，
不是说全都用，
但是有一部分车型都会用，
甚至于斯特兰蒂斯跟三星还在欧洲合资建厂，
但是最新的消息就是斯特兰蒂斯基本上就自己不去射足新能源了，
因为斯特兰蒂斯本身是投资零跑的，
所以零跑的一些车型就会放到欧洲来直接就本土化，
那么你想想看零跑它在国内的销量还是相当可观的，
所以它肯定也会带一些供应商直接到欧洲去，
这还没完，
三星最近还刚刚拿下了奔驰的新订单，
就是给奔驰的下一代的电池去供应电池，
所以说三星跟欧洲这边车企的关系确实不错，
它一直想走的路就是它不去拼规模，
它要拼高端，
然后它就主攻欧洲的豪华品牌，
所以它也知道想要走规模根本干不过国内的零德时代这些品牌，
所以只能是跟欧洲车企出号关系，
然后做它的高端品牌的三元力电池，
其实日韩的电池供应商现在也可以说是被逼出来的，
也可以说可能是他们的一个共性就是会过度依赖单一的车企，
你比如说像松下跟LG就非常的依赖特斯拉，
尤其是特斯拉的Model Y这一款车型，
这个风险是非常大的，
你要知道特斯拉我们今天一直在讲，
它的电池供应商已经从4家扩展到了5家，
那么新网达的加入肯定是会对LG和松下会有非常大的影响，
因为他们俩本身蛋糕分的已经是不多了，
我们知道零德时代的这个蛋糕比例是最大的嘛，对吧，
那么这两家分的本来就不多，
又来个新网达要过来抢吃的，抢蛋糕，
他们俩肯定也不开心嘛，
但是这只是一个开始，
这只是开始，如果说特斯拉发现新网达的东西真的是物美驾连，
那我觉得松下跟LG往后的日子可能会越来越难，
甚至能不能吃上这碗饭都不好说，
好吧，那么今天以上就是关于新网达成为特斯拉第5家电视供应商，
以及这背后的一些故事，
给大家来展开来聊了聊了也四十多分钟了，
那么希望大家喜欢，
如果觉得节目不错呢，
可以去订阅本频道，
如果是新听有听到这里的，
动动发台的手指，
在喜马拉雅，
包括小宇宙的平台上，
可以点一下订阅，
每周三每周六更新会有提醒，
那么同时每期节目的评论区，
欢迎大家热烈的评论，
那么我们下期节目就是每一次都会抽取，
上一期的三条评论，
做一个互动，
那么每一位都可以获得由任严计提供的，
非常好吃的郁路香梨，
试试装，
里面一盒有五颗，
如果觉得好吃也可以上我的小程序，
摆车全说，
这个小程序里面进行选购，
好的，我们来看一看上期节目的留言互动啊，
上期节目呢，
咱们聊的是八连之后电动车真的会报废吗，
也是我们的一个听有的投稿，
评论区里面反响还是非常好的，
很多人讲说就想听一听这种真实用户，
特别是电车用户长期使用之后的一些感受，
那么其实这些素材我有很多，
那以后有机会我就挑选一些，
放在节目当中来给大家做解读，
好，我们看看上期的留言啊，
其实第一条留言是非常长的一条留言，
写了估计有两千多字，
分享了他的自己的生活，
以及他的用车的一些感受，
他的名字叫做三刀面管的金卡顾客，
这一听就是老听有，
因为大家都知道我最想的就是退休之后看一个三刀面管啊，
他说三刀你好，我是一名老听有了，
平时呢非常认真的听节目，
但是我从来没有参与过留言或者互动，
你应该是我最熟悉的陌生人，
说熟悉的是因为每天上下班的路上固定会有你的声音陪伴，
说陌生是因为我们从未谋面，
那么作为一名四年的纯电车主，
我也想把自己从最初接触汽车买车用车的感受，
以及日后对车的一些想法分享给大家，
他说我是标准的驾校学员，
考了驾到之后开车技术还不过关，
于是每个周末我就开着手动档的劫达去外面练车，
顺便到龙家乐吃吃喝喝，
随着时间的推移开车的技术也是越来越熟练了，
换档是越来越丝滑，
唯一的遗憾就是副驾没有那个他，
这小词写的还挺压运啊，
他说那段时间真的很开心，
车子呢给我带来了很多的快乐，
主要是源于世界好像一下子就变小了，
我的活动半径突然之间就变大了，
让我感觉就像小时候刚学会骑自行车的时候，
每天放学回家第一时间就是赶紧把作业写完，
饭都顾不上吃，
就登着自行车冲上马路，
感受着风划过脸庞，
世界好像一下子就变小了，
我哪里都可以去，
当时我后座上还带着我的妹妹，
往返40多公里去春游，
现在想想真带劲啊，
骑着自行车往返40公里，
我的天哪，
你这要换到现在的话，
你应该是个骑行爱好者啊，
他说2007年呢我结婚了，
婚后没有第一时间买车，
因为当时车辆对于我们来讲并不是刚需，
媳妇单位呢就在家的旁边，
下楼就到单位了，
我的单位呢也离家不远，
做公交，
哪怕走路都行，
偶尔天气不好的时候我也可以蹭一下同事的车子，
2011年老大出生了，
也就是结婚四年之后老大出生了，
为了迎接这个小生命的到来呢，
我们做了很多的准备，
其中一项就是准备买车，
我们家里面选购了一辆2.0自然吸气的马泽达6，
那么对于这款车的印象其实很好，
开起来很省心，
刚买车的头几年呢我还出去到CS店保养，
后来呢给我保养的这个技师出来担干了，
开了个修理厂，
我也就再也没去过CS店了，
我也就去他的店里面保养，
那么这辆车呢陪伴我和家人度过了非常多开心快乐的时光，
也陪我度过了最青春的时光，
现在想一想心里面还是很怀念的，
有一句话说的好，
你怀念一座城市，
是因为那座城市里面有让你怀念的人，
我觉得车也是同样的道理，
他见证了我出为人妇的兴奋，
也承载过我加班的疲惫，
更加分享过我出游的确悦，
虽然说现在我不知道他在何方，
但那些关于他的记忆，
却像老照片一样，
在心底里面预发的清晰，
温暖如初，
在这里我想向他道一声谢，
老伙计你辛苦了，
哎呀这段话其实说的我都，
谈不上说眼泪流出来那么夸张啊，
但是我心里面真的是，
啊有一点，
那种就是温暖就暖流吧，
因为我不想讲暖流，
因为我说不清楚这个话啊，
乐乐不分，
南京人讲不清楚，
真的有一股暖流，
因为我家女儿出身的那一晚，
我就记得当时是，
我老婆说肚子有反应了，
然后呢我就赶紧我就下楼，
我说你赶紧我就，
我妈就收拾东西嘛，
因为全家都知道预产期就那么几天，
我就坐上了我的CRV，
我当时记得CRV里面还放着那个，
就是哈狗帮的rap，
所以我家女儿是听着rap出身的，
你知道吗，
就听着那个哈狗帮MCDog的那个rap，
在那里面逮你光浪在那里面放着音乐，
我那时候有点紧张，
我已经忘了把这个收音机，
就是我的这个，
那个还不叫收音机啊，
你应该叫什么呢，
就是忘了把我的这个MP3给它关掉，
然后我媳妇就挺着个大肚子，
然后我妈就扶着她就下楼，
就上了我的车，
夜里面差不多12点多一点，
凌晨12点多，
然后我家媳妇最后是早上几点我就不说了，
因为这里面涉及到深层八字什么的，
反正是早上升的，
我家女儿早上升的，
所以当时一直是开着我的CRV，
然后中途她忘拿了几样东西，
我还开着她回到家里面，
又拿了几样东西，
然后再开过去，
当时我媳妇生孩子全程的录像我都有，
因为一上车我就拿这个DV，
我还对着她拍了一下，
我说哎，
我说媳妇你什么感受，
老公疼说又没力气，
然后什么的，
说赶紧赶紧开车了，
你别录像了，
你全录在那个录像机里面，
所以现在如果回头看一看，
真的很有意思啊，
我当时拿了一个索尼的DV嘛，
当时我就一下楼第一反应，
因为我之前想过很多次这个画面了，
就是我老婆要生孩子，
我一定要把它记录下来，
所以你看我没做自媒体之前，
就一直是一个喜欢记录的人，
然后继续看她的这个留言，
她说时间过得很快，
2014年老大上一二月了，
2015年搬家，
2016年老二出生，
你这效率挺高的啊，
她说2017年老大上小学，
2020年老二上一二月，
2022年单位搬迁，
2023年老大上初中，
2023年老二上小学，
2026年老大即将迎来中考，
那就是说老大比我们家要大个两岁啊，
对吧，我们家初一嘛，你们家中考，
她说在这个期间啊，
2022年其实很重要，
因为2022年我经历了两件事情，
一个就是单位搬迁，
一个就是换车，
因为单位抽建新楼是我负责的，
啊，管这是个大领导，
所以说我对于搬迁的时间掌握的很精准，
单位的新址在城市的北郊，
那么附近公交不是很完善，
距离最近的地铁站还有三到四公里，
而我家在城市的南郊，
因为我每天还得接娃放学，
那么这样一来的话，
我上下班就没办法去选择公交车了，
开车的话有两个方案，
方案第一个就是穿城而过，
就穿越这个城市，
距离比较近，
但是红绿灯比较多，
那么主城区堵车的概率也很大，
通勤时间不确定，
因为我每天下午要接孩子，
所以第一个方案基本上不可选，
第二个方案就是走绕城高速，
距离比较远，
但是不堵车，
通勤时间基本可控，
绕城高速也可以包连，
就是他讲的应该是过路费啊，
就是包连是300块钱，
那么我家和单位都在绕城高速沿线，
上下也方便，
就是上高速下高速也方便，
他说公寓善其是必先利其其，
我就开始琢磨换车了，
我想换一辆电车，
原因如下，
所以你看这个哥们儿写东西，
就跟他这个造房子规划一样的，
就是你看，
其实条条框框就非常清晰，
他说第一，
我家走高速到单位的话单乘35公里，
一天往返一次就是70公里，
油车说实话成本是比较高的，
那么第二一点就是我家是固定车位，
是可以安装充电框的，
单位也是统一安装的充电框，
充电非常的方便，
就是抬手的事情，
那么既然想好了我就开始看车，
诉求非常的明确，
第一纯电车啊直买电车，
第二续航一定要长一点，
第三空间要稍微大一点，
2022年的时候满足这些条件的车，
其实并不多，
大概的方向有三个，
特斯拉，
未来,
比亚迪，
那么出于某些原因，
特斯拉没有选，
你不要某些原因的，
你不就是，
就是把公务员或者事业单位嘛，
对吧,
这肯定是因为这个所以没有选嘛，
好多特斯拉没有选，
就放弃了，
那么剩下来就是未来和比亚迪了嘛，
我重点看了未来ES6和比亚迪的塘，
未来ES6是我看上的首选车型，
但是我最终选了比亚迪，
纯电730公里的版本，
他说媳妇当时也是同时换力量游车，
宝马的三系，
那么我选比亚迪的原因如下，
他说了四点，
我的天这哥们是，
每一件事情都会一二三四，
应该是学理科的，
他说第一点就是，
未来ES6里程短，
换电不是我的钢区，
我家和单位充电又很方便，
换电站，
单位附近是没有的，
家附近是有换电站，
但是不是我顺路的方向，
我还得专门开过去，
所以对于我来讲吸引力不大，
第二个就是未来的内饰，
虽然说给我感觉还挺好，
但是很多我喜欢的配置都要选装，
所以算下来之后，
整体的售价远远高于比亚迪堂，
虽然说可以租电，
但是整体算下来费用还是高，
而且堂是可以选六座版本的，
这一点非常受孩子的欢迎，
后期的使用也确实如此，
因为它毕竟是个二台家庭，
他说第三点，
就是当时比亚迪堂的中空大屏，
看起来确实比未来ES6的中空，
数评更加的让孩子喜欢，
第四一点，
就是比亚迪的刀片电池对我来讲，
更有吸引力，
那么在2022年的9月份我就提了新车，
比亚迪堂纯电730公里，
加了1万块钱升级成了六座版本，
目前这个车辆已经行使了将近9万公里，
出过两次小问题，
一次是副驾驶的手套箱，
那个手套箱的阻尼失效了，
第二个就是左后门的玻璃伸降按键失效了，
那么到店里面直接给你免费换新的，
也没多大问题，
8万公里的时候呢，
我是整体换过一次轮胎，
其他一切正常没有出过任何问题，
也许是因为单位搬迁的原因，
2022年我提车之后，
单位很多的同事都开始换车了，
那么除去一辆问界，
剩下的全是比亚迪堂，
比亚迪送，
比亚迪请，
比亚迪远，
比亚迪还囤，
他说单位的车库已经快成比亚迪的车展了，
哈哈哈，
他说当然了，
车子的品牌慢慢的吩咐了起来，
也有其他的像大众啊，日产啊，
还有像理想传奇这些都是，
但这些车都是新能源，
所以说你们当地，
我估计都是冲着你们公司的那个，
你们单位的那个免费的充电桩巨大，
我估计是，
而且你们当地应该，
我估计房价不贵吧，
所以可能这个，
四人的车位是比较丰富的，
而且都是低面车位或者是平面车位，
所以好装充电桩，
都是算这笔账嘛，
而且你一听就是你是在起事，
就是那种事业或者是公务员的单位里面，
你们收入肯定也不低啊，
至少比当地普通老百姓要高很多，
所以房子一定是住的比较好的小区，
然后又有自己的车位，
然后你们的这个，
这个起事业单位里面又有充电桩，
那谁不买新能源啊，
换我我也买新能源啊，
他说在换车之初，
我当时就想好了，
我就买新能源车，
因为我觉得新能源车更符合我的生活场景，
后来也证实了我的想法，
他说又开始写1234了，
他说第一，
每天上下班通勤更加的经济，
对吧,
这就不用说了嘛，
第二,
节假日孩子补贺，
哎,
我就省去了找停车场和逛街花钱的痛苦，
路边一停，空调一开，
停停三道的节目，
对吧,
休息休息，
瞇着眼睛，
小小气一会儿，
很爽啊，
第三,
中控大屏是孩子的最爱，
路上看动画片，
那是力气啊，
对不对，
你跟我一样，
对孩子一看就是管的比较松的，
在路上一边开车，
一边能看视频，
有的家长是不让看的，
那我们是管的比较松，
上车看的无所谓，
但我们家孩子现在对上车看视频，
已经没什么兴趣了，
他更想上车看手机，
那他妈不让他看手机，
就是在上车看手机跟上车看视频，
就是看车机的屏幕之间，
如果一定要二选一，
那我相信任何父母一定是给他看，
车机的屏幕不让他看手机的，
是不是，
他第四点就是有一定的智能功能，
虽然说和现在的车没法比，
但是当时的体验远远好过我的马斯达六，
因为他当时买车是2022年，
他说现在家里面一共是两台车，
一个就是比亚迪的这个堂，
还有就是媳妇开的宝马三细，
一个游车，一个电车，
但是两个孩子其实更喜欢比亚迪堂，
每次出门都说啊要开堂要开堂要开堂这个车，
可以看动画片，
可以跟小迪聊天，
有独立座椅，
每个人就一人一个嘛，
大家就坐在那边想看什么想干什么都可以，
互不干扰，
其实想一想，
这大概就是时代赋予我们这一代人独特的体验，
从手动脑的劫达，
到自动脑的马斯达，
再到稍微智能化一点的比亚迪堂，
我们这一代人对于汽车的感受也在迭代身体，
那么汽车对于我们来讲，
从交通工具变成了智能生活的空间，
当初选择行动员更多是出于经济账和长鲜的心态，
没想到他却以一种润悟细无声的方式。
彻底改变了我们家庭出行的质感，
孩子们也不会说把坐车当成是一种负担，
反而会当成一段难得的娱乐时光，
看着他们握在宽大的座椅里面，
对着小迪忽来忽去，
那种无忧无虑的笑声，
比任何发动机的轰鸣声都来得越耳，
这段写的真的非常棒啊，
他说，我怀念旧车，
因为我真心那段时光，
我享受新车，
因为我更期待触手可及的便利与温馨，
车再变，技术再变，
但那一份宰着家人去往幸福目的地的初心始终未变。
他说这篇文章我勾丝了好几天，
那么碍于时间有限，
平时上班又比较忙，
我利用午饭后的一点时间，
抓紧时间赶紧完成，
还有很多的想说的话，
没有展开来写，
希望兄弟们理解，
也是希望三刀的面馆早日开业，
我虽然不在南京，
但是我一定冲到你的店里面冲一个金卡，
不一定能当绑一大哥，
但绝对是真心实意的，
就是金盆银盆不如卖面的铜盆，
卖面的生意，
先经流和稳定性那是不容置疑的。
最后我想说的就是，
人都是先活的立体的有情绪的，
我们大家都只是通过单一的渠道。
接触到三刀的一个方面，
或者几个方面，
那么在这种情况下，
大家很容易将某些标签，
或者某一段经历，
误以为是它的全部，
我们接触到的或许只是片面的三刀，
却忽略了它作为一个普通人，
同样会有一地鸡毛和脆弱的一面。
正如那句话所说，
人都是片面的看别人，
但没有人是片面的活着，
让我们试着放下预设，
去理解情绪背后的逻辑，
去接纳不完美，
但真实的侧面。
谢谢大家。
我的天呐，
真的写的非常的好，
说实话，
你让我憋一个月，
我也写不出这样的文章，
这里面不仅仅有真实的经历，
有你的感受，
而且有那种很唯美的画面，
有很多的排笔，
很多的比喻，
我觉得真的很强，
很强。
所以我觉得，
要不你找盾牌，
把我的微信推一下，
咱们联系联系，
对吧,
哪个城市，
哪个单位的，
哈哈哈。
这哥们一看，
个人成长的经历，
也是非常的丰富，
然后用车经历，
我觉得你2022年买的，
现在是2026年四年，
也差不多，
再过个一两年，
该换车了，
孩子初中毕业，
今年中考，
上了高中，
我不知道是去外地，
还是去哪，
对吧,
你这么值得庆祝的一件事情，
不赶紧把车给换了嘛，
哈哈哈，
挺不错的，
挺好的。
啊,
这个,
有人讲说，
三刀逆以后，
是不是都读这么长的留言，
不是不是，
我只是觉得这条留言，
真的是，
就可以讲说这个，
非常出众，
啊,
就是这个就，
贺利剧情的这种内心，
就是我长期看到大家的留言，
突然来了一篇，
长文我也见过很多，
但是长文又写的非常好，
而且,
这个逻辑清晰，
然后语言组织各方面，
包括文笔文采，
都非常不错的，
不太多节，
因为我知道有些人，
他在做长留言的时候，
第一个会通过语音，
直接在手机上输入，
然后第二个会通过AR，
去进行一些润色，
然后到了我这里，
我再去读的过程当中，
有的时候体感不是特别的好，
还有一些呢，
大家在打字的时候呢，
错别字他也不改，
他可能就打完就直接发出去了，
也没有回看，
还有一些就是嗯，
怎么讲呢，
他可能就是口语话，
他平时的表达，
他自己没有感觉，
就是上下文的逻辑，
包括一些，
这个行文的这种，
怎么讲呢，
就是通顺啊，
就是让人家读感，
节奏感，
会稍微差一点，
所以有的时候，
你要听我读留言，
你自己留的言，
你会发现，
三刀我在读的过程当中，
其实给你的留言不完全一样，
因为我自己，
要把它稍微在，
就是保持原意的情况下，
稍微改一改，
但是这篇文章，
我是一个字都没有改，
它写的非常不错，
好，我们再看下一位啊，
下一位叫做，
究极江龙炮二，
他说三刀，
分享一下我的电车经历，
15年我在北京摇行人员，
当时直接给号，
买的是江淮REV5，
用车体验很好啊，
我的理念就是，
根据续航去跑多远的地方，
哎，你看，
我们是，
跑多远的地方，
然后去，
去测算一下，
就是我们规划去哪充电，
它是根据续航去跑，
他说,
我不要去超出，
就远超出续航能力的地方，
这样的话能减轻非常多的理神焦虑，
你不能把它当成游车用，
想去哪就去哪，
我有私人充电庄，
然后我充电庄是一块两毛五每度电，
不便宜啊，
他私人充电庄还要一块两毛五啊，
但他一块会解释为什么，
他说我基本上回到家，
插上充电庄，
我就直接上楼睡觉去了，
每一天满电出发体验很好，
每一年大概3000多的电费，
那么对比后来摇到了游车，
我的游车是加95号的油，
我一年的油费要1万块，
你想电车3000块，油车1万块，
那确实电车很省啊，
买车花了8万，
开了10年，
那现在肯定是不值钱了嘛，
拿个报费补贴2万，
那就直接给他换了，
10万公里到最后，
其实我的电路板坏了一次，
当时是因为接触不良，
SS电还是比较良心的，
出宝之前的三个月，
给我换了新的电路板，
让我直接省了1万多块钱，
电池的衰减肯定是有的，
我纯电上下班玩反40公里，
我的空调是一直开着的都不关的，
我的车基本上两天充一次，
他说道哥我想提醒你一下，
北京充电基本上都是在。
1块6到1块8，
1块8上下，很贵很贵的，
然后下面就有人回复他的评论，
有网友讲说，
江淮IEV5这个车，
我当时印象中问题很多啊，
锁电，大规模的自然，
续航很低，
还有非常致命的压差一致性的问题，
然后车主就回复他，
他说,
当年其实也没什么车可血，
市面上大部分都是油改电，
续航低，
但是你续航低你要有一个匹配的价格，
所以看来看去就觉得江淮这个车，
价格跟续航是比较匹配的，
对吧,
他说,
我这个车至少开到现在，
目前是没什么大毛病的，
那么下面这个听友又问了说，
北京的私人充电桩，
1块2毛5一度电，
这么贵吗？
不是说这个什么分股电价5毛3毛吗？
全国难道不统一吗？
然后他这个车主就回复说，
我们小区是物业统一馆，
那么就是这个价，
确实是贵的，
对，1块2毛5是不便宜，
你像我在南京的话，
我家门口的充电桩便宜的时候，
我能充到8毛9毛的，
我在那个拍摄视频的。
河西清澳村充电桩，
最便宜我能充到6毛多的，
对吧,
我平时从那基本上不看价格的话，
那就是1块到1块1、1块2，
所以你这个就是长期在自己的车位上的。
私人充电桩上充都要1块2毛5，
所以北京真不是一般人能带得起的地方，
下面一位听友叫做欧阳T7BS，
他说你好到哥，
听您的节目很多年了，
听到你节目当中提及低电费要半夜去充电，
我想说说我们这里的情况，
我在陕西西安，
我们就是经营充电站的，
我不知道江苏是什么情况，
我们这边大部分的电站都参与了市场化购电，
这也是最近执行的一个，
就是在购电公司去买它的电，
就是购电，
那么现在一天当中，
电价的股值是早上的10点到下午的4点，
这和很多人想法是不一样的，
早上10点到下午4点，
是一天的分股电价里面的股值最便宜的时候，
所以它不像以前国网售电的时候是0点到早上6点，
他说这个我想跟你去同步一下信息，
也是祝三刀身体健康事实顺利，
谢谢，非常感谢，
这个信息非常有用，
那么根据你的信息我上网也查了一下，
我觉得挺有意思的，
那么的确它各个省份电价最便宜的时间段是不一样的，
这个里面其实主要是在于什么，
就是我们以前觉得说夜里面充电一定是便宜的嘛，
为什么，
因为大家都睡觉了，用电比较少，
工厂也停工了嘛，
因为工厂也是用电大户对不对，
所以说社会的就用电需求低了，
那么国家鼓励大家就是，
你能在夜里充电，
能在夜里去用电，
那电价就便宜对吧，
拉平它的附和，
但是现在不一样，
特别是西部的这些城市就是不一样，
为什么，
西部是反而白天的电价更便宜，
因为像陕西，
像西北的很多地方，
它的新能源的发电比例比较高，
什么叫新能源发电比例比较高呢，
就是比方说用光幅，
那么中午就是大白天，
太阳是最大的，
光幅的发电量爆炸式的增长，
所以你会发现中午那几个小时，
电是多到用不完，
那么这个时候如果没有人去用电，
光幅就只能是限电，
那就是白白浪费了嘛，
所以现在很多地方的古电，
已经是从过去的半夜，
已经是转移到了现在的白天，
特别是西部地区，
就是大量用光幅发电的，
那么大家一直在讨论一个问题，
说新能源到底是不是真正的清洁能源，
说很多地方都是用火电，
我们用的电里面，
其实很多一部分用的都是火力发电，
但是实际上在西部很多城市，
特别是白天中午的时候，
他们用到这个电，
中午充的话，
它应该是光幅发电，
就是太阳晒出来的电，
居多一点，
所以说现在很多新能源车主，
还在坚持说半夜去充电，
特别是西部城市的车主，
你实际上已经是老黄利益要翻篇了，
你去了解一下，
就是如果是通过市场化采购这个电的话，
那么应该是中午这个时阶段，
是最便宜的时候西部地区，
那么至于说，
咱们南京江苏或者是周边让北上广长江沿岸，
这些城市有没有可能是光幅发电也多了，
然后中午也便宜了，
不得而知，
大家可以去看一下这个电价的一些变化，
各个省份它不一样，
因为现在是市场化的运作，
所以全国各地的这些充电厂站的运营商，
它就会根据它采购的电价来进行实施调整，
所以可能有的地方还是凌晨不要12点到早上6点很便宜，
但是像西部有些地方，
那就是中午这一段时间是最便宜的，
它是实时跟着电力市场走的，
不再是简单的按照居民的分股用电的价格来进行规划了，
所以你会发现真的是很有意思这个事情，
你要不是专业人士跟你去偷这么一醉，
你可能都不知道有这么回事，
所以也是非常感谢这位听友，
我觉得咱们的节目不是我一个人做的，
是我们相互完成的一个作品，
我在节目当中抛出一个观点，
做一些内容，抛专影域，
然后大家在评论区里面也会补充很多自己的建文，
甚至就是这个行业内的一些专业人士，
大家在评论区会进行讨论，
这点非常的好，
所以大家如果在喜马拉雅小宇宙听我的节目，
也不要忘了可以去评论区看一看，
也许有更加值得关注的信息，
好吧,
那么以上就是本期节目所有内容给大家收听，
如果觉得节目不错可以点赞评论跟转发，
那么每期节目的评论区会抽三位，
赠送由任严计提供的鱼鹵香梨，
想吃想买的话也可以上我们的小程序摆车全说进行选购，
那么同时我有更多的原创内容，
大家可以关注Bilibili摆车全说这个账号，
也可以关注我的微博摆车全说三刀，
还有我的公众号也叫摆车全说，
那么短视频账号比较多，
小红书，抖音，快手视频号，
这些你都可以去关注一个号叫做三刀砍车，
单人旁砍大山的砍，
那么同时隔壁也有我的一党双人对台内的节目，
就是跟我的好朋友们之间，
去聊各行各业的一些有趣的剑文，
那么叫小声流刀，
事情的事，
那么如果觉得咱们这一张专辑还不够听的话，
也可以去隔壁的专辑里面去听一听，
那么如果想联系我，
想跟我一对一的交流也可以加微信，
4641 5254,。
好的今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下一期接着聊，
拜拜!